we are told that a sample of a compound
containing only carbon and hydrogen
atoms is completely combusted producing
five point six five grams of carbon
dioxide and three point four seven grams
of h2o or water what is the empirical
formula of the compound so pause this
video and see if you can work through
that all right now let's just try to
make sure we understand what's going on
they say that I have some mystery
compound it only contains carbon and
hydrogen so it's going to have some
number of carbon I'll call that X some
number of hydrogen's I'll call that Y
we're going to put it in the presence of
molecular oxygen and it's going to
combust and after its combusted I'm
going to end up with some carbon dioxide
and some water and what I just drew here
this is a chemical reaction that I'm
describing I haven't balanced it i I
could try to even with the X's and Y's
but that's not the point of this video
the point of this video is they tell us
how many grams of the carbon dioxide we
have and how many grams of the water we
have they tell us that right over there
and so what we need to do is say alright
from that we can figure out how many
moles of carbon dioxide we have how many
moles of water we have and from that we
can figure out how many moles of carbon
did we start with and how many moles of
hydrogen did we start with and if we
look at those ratios then we can come up
with the empirical formula of the
compound so just to start because I'm
going to be thinking about molar moles
and molar masses and and and the mass of
a mole of a molecule or an atom let's
just get the average atomic mass for
carbon hydrogen and oxygen for us to
work with so I'll get out our handy
periodic table we can see hydrogen has
an average atomic mass of 1.008 let me
write that down so we have hydrogen is
that one point zero zero eight and then
we have carbon and carbon is at
12.01 so carbon is that 12.01 and we
could also think about them in terms of
molar masses we could say this is gram
per mole grams per mole and then last
but not least we have oxygen and then
oxygen is at 16 point zero zero grams
per mole this is average atomic mass but
then we can think of that as molar mass
that that number is molar mass so oxygen
is that 16 point zero zero grams per
mole and so now we can try to figure out
how many moles of C in the product do we
have so we can see that all the carbon
in the product is in the carbon dioxide
that's in the product and so we have
five point six five grams of co2 we can
think about how many moles of co2 that
is so times one mole of co2 for every
how many grams of co2 well we just have
to think about actually let me just put
it right over here
co2 you're going to have let's say you
have one carbon and two oxygens
so it is going to be twelve point zero 1
plus 2 times 16 2 x 1600 grams per mole
and so let's see this would get us to
this is 32 plus 12 point oh 1 so that is
44 point oh one and that's grams per
mole but now we're thinking about moles
per gram so it's going to be one over
forty four point zero one and so when we
did just this the grams of co2 would
cancel with the grams of co2 and this
would give us moles of co2 but I care
about moles of carbon in the product so
how many moles of carbon
are there for every mole of co2 well we
know that we have one mole of carbon for
every one mole of co2 every carbon
dioxide molecule has one carbon in it
and so what is this going to get us so
we have five point six five divided by
divided by forty four point zero one and
then times one so I don't have to do
anything there that is equal to I'll
round it to three digits here so zero
point one two eight so this is zero
point one two eight and my units here
are this e the grams of carbon dioxide
cancel with the grams of carbon dioxide
the moles of carbon dioxide cancel with
the moles of carbon dioxide so I am
exactly where I want to be this is how
many moles of carbon that I have and you
can do the dimensional analysis but it
also makes intuitive sense hopefully if
this is how many grams of carbon dioxide
we have and a mole of carbon dioxide is
going to have a mass of 44 0.01 grams
well then five point six five over this
is going to tell us how what fraction of
a mole we have of carbon dioxide and
then whatever that number of moles we
have of carbon dioxide's going to be the
same as the moles of carbon because we
have one atom of carbon for every carbon
dioxide molecule so that all makes sense
and now let's do the same for hydrogen
so let's think about moles of hydrogen
in the product it's going to be the same
exercise and if you're so inspired and
if you didn't calculate it in the
beginning I encourage you to try to do
this part on your own alright so all of
the hydrogen is in the water so and we
know that we have in our product three
point four seven grams of water three
point four seven grams of h2o and now
let's think about how many moles of h2o
that is so that's going to be let's see
every one mole of h2o is going to have a
mass of how many grams of h2o and we
could do that up here
h2o it's going to be we have two
hydrogen's so it's going to be two times
1.008
plus the mass the average atomic mass of
the oxygen it's going to be plus sixteen
but we can also view that as what would
be the mass in grams if you had a mole
of it and so this is going to be in
grams per mole and so this is going to
be let's see two times one point zero
zero right this part over here is two
point zero one six and then you add 16
to it it's going to be eighteen point
zero one six eighteen point zero one six
and then if I just calculated this this
would give me how many moles of water I
have in my product but I care about mole
moles of hydrogen and so how many moles
of hydrogen do I ever have for every
mole of water so for how many moles of
hydrogen for every mole of water well
I'm going to have two moles of hydrogen
for every mole of water because in each
water molecule I have two hydrogen's and
so that's going to cancel out with that
and we're just going to be left with
moles of hydrogen and so this is going
to be equal to I'll take my three point
four seven grams of water divide it by
the how much how many grams a mole of
water about what its mass would be so
divided by eighteen point zero one six
this is how many moles of water I have
and now for every for every molecule of
water I have two hydrogen's so then I
will multiply by two times two is equal
to zero point I'll just around three
digits right over here zero point three
eight five zero point three eight five
moles of hydrogen so now we we know the
number of hydrogen atoms we know the
number of carbon atoms and to figure out
the empirical formula of the compound we
can think about the ratio between the
two so I'm gonna find the ratio of
hydrogen's to
carbons and that is going to be equal to
I have 0.38 five moles of hydrogen over
over 0.128 moles of carbon 0.128 moles
of carbon and what is this equal to
and it looks like it's going to be
roughly three but let me verify that in
my head that seems so I already have the
hydrogen there and so if I divide it by
zero point one two eight I get yep
pretty close to three now actually I
think if I yep pretty close to three so
there you go this is approximately three
and so I can with pretty good conference
this this was very close to three I can
say for every carbon I have three
hydrogen's in my original compound and
this thing right over here so the
empirical formula of our original
compound for every one carbon I have
three hydrogen's so ch3 and we are done